a floresta entrou na minha vida né
e se recusou e começou a gerar frutos da
floresta em si mas os frutos que a
floresta tem proporcionado né pra mim
minha família vizinhos
quero dizer que o brasil tem passado e
vendo a floresta tem promovido muitas
coisas maravilhosas e tem também aberto
vários horizontes na vida da sociedade
que têm aderido a esse grande exemplo de
cultivo sistemas agroflorestais
assim fazendo com que as pessoas
desperte para outras criatividade pela
liberdade que ela nos dá no campo né
o sítio onde eu trabalho
ele começou em 2000
o primeiro passo em 2002 a gente começou
a ver a grande diferença que fazia do
sistema convencional executivo para o
sistema de consórcios né das provas
juntas que o sistema florestais ea gente
começou também a imaginar coisas como a
gente poderia estar melhorando cada vez
mais o nosso equilíbrio e foi criado o
projeto se chama agroecoturismo né
quero uma forma da recente wando
trazendo os agricultores da nossa região
para um movimento onde a gente pudesse
desenvolver várias iniciativas já que a
região litorânea toda trabalha em função
de turismo vive em função do turismo e
tem o turismo como a fonte de renda para
quem mora do ecoturismo
ele vem inserindo o sistema de produção
inicialmente né
e dentro do sistema de produção criando
outras linhas de desenvolvimento que é
chegar até o produto final que a gente
sonha que está caminhando
várias coisas a gente avançou ea água
floresta ela proporciona alimentos ea
nossa meta é que o produto florestal
seja reconhecido como um produto
diferenciado né e seja agregado valor
isso valorizando a mão de obra dos
agricultores
nós vamos avançar ainda estamos
avançando é claro é uma coisa é um
projeto de vida um sistema planetário
nos dá um projeto de vida
dentro disso tem um movimento de
chama-se agroecologia que agrega todos
os os trabalhos que são de forma
sustentáveis né sustentáveis não é a
única forma de sustentabilidade mas no
contexto geral nós precisamos sustentar
o meio ambiente eo ecossistema mas com a
nossa qualidade de vida também segura
a partir do momento que a gente pensa só
humana com boa qualidade com saúde
a gente tem condições melhor de
alimentar o planeta também pensando
nessa linha a gente vem trabalhando
também um outro etapa do projeto de água
o ecoturismo que é a gastronomia
sustentável porque gastronomia
sustentável é fácil fazer a gastronomia
sustentável
todo mundo pode usar esse nome ok estou
vendendo a gastronomia sustentável mas a
gastronomia sustentável ela tem uma
exigência ea exigência nós chamamos dos
dez mandamentos da gastronomia
sustentável
a gastronomia sustentável não é
sustentável quando ela começa
sustentando a partir do produtivo
implantar de forma ecologicamente
correta
livre de qualquer solução químicos fazer
o trabalho de educação educar o o
agricultor a comunidade
o executivo né pra que ele produza o
produto 100% saudável garante no a
sustentabilidade do ecossistema em sua
volta e esse produto chegando no
restaurante ou em qualquer outro lugar
de consumo de pessoas que adere a esse
produto sendo valorizado e se for um
restaurante uma pousada a fornecido para
os seus clientes
a gente está pensando no planeta
saudável
a gente tá pensando num ecossistema
equilibrado o agroturismo também que vem
a educação do turista
o turista nossa obrigação é educar o
turista tudo isto tem que vem pra nossa
casa nós estamos educadores dele para
que ele saiba respeitar o ambiente para
que ele saiba se comportar dentro do
ambiente trazer ele pro campo trabalhar
com a gente aprender a forma de cultivo
com sistemas agroflorestais
isso tudo é desenvolvido dentro de si
nesse programa agro ecoturismo
porque o que a gente entende em que a
gente precisa do ecossistema
porém a gente perdemos os hábitos de
viver de forma harmônica com tudo isso e
quando a gente começa a trabalhar os
sistemas agroflorestais
a gente começa identificar as falhas que
nós humanos
cometemos contra nós mesmos cada ser e
da natureza cada uma planta que a gente
se machuca a gente tá machucado nós
mesmos então quando a gente
identificamos isso dentro do movimento
que nós fazemos um movimento de
agroecologia né
a gente entende que nós temos a
responsabilidade de educar aqueles que
ainda não têm a oportunidade não tiveram
e não convive com o meio ambiente como
um todo
dentro dessa linha a gente vem
trabalhando é a educação
buscando
esse elo que a gente já está conseguindo
fazer muito bem feito está muito bem
engajada é conectando restaurantes
pousadas grandes hotéis com a produção
agroecológica para que nós possamos
estar divulgando esse trabalho não na
forma apenas as pessoas conhecer o nosso
produto e nos comprar ele mas na forma
da gente educar o consumidor para que
ele possa começar direcionar se de fato
a buscar um produto de qualidade à saúde
humana está em jogo né
e nós sabemos temos certeza nós que
talvez muita gente que não possa ter
firmeza disso mas nós que trabalhamos
com tecnologia nós temos certeza que a
grande
o grande problema da saúde humana é
através dos alimentos
as pessoas precisam de fato conhecer uma
outra forma de se alimentar e nós temos
esse compromisso de mostrar esse produto
né
ainda somos muito pequenos não
produzimos em larga escala porque a
agricultura à agricultura ecológica ela
não proporciona uma larga escala como
faz o agronegócio mas ela proporciona
uma grande diversidade de produtos à
alimentação brasileira é muito
diversificada e os sistemas
agroflorestais e ele nos proporciona e
nos faça essa diversificação para nós
poder apresentar para o nosso cliente
aqueles que nos que nos procuram aquele
que nós conquistamos até ao longo do
nosso trabalho
os sistemas agroflorestais
é o que nós vemos hoje como uma saída
para a saúde humana e também do planeta
é o que nós vemos como uma solução para
que nós possamos barra
o avanço da destruição da nossa floresta
para que nós possamos fazer
enfrentamento ao sistema
predador que vem cada vez mais se
avançando eu sou apenas uma formiguinha
dentro do movimento que existe a nível
nacional
temos grandes movimentos e dividimos em
alguns sistemas agroflorestais agrícola
os dias é temperar culturas e por aí vai
que trabalhando nessa defesa da saúde
humana o nosso objetivo é produzir
alimentos de qualidade para colocar na
mesa né agregar mais pessoas fazem a
educação porque as pessoas consiga
começar a se identificar com os sistemas
agroflorestais e viu fazer essa esse
intercâmbio conosco para que a gente
possa crescer e avançar com o nosso
sistema
nós fazemos isso
já em parte temos vários agricultores
hoje nós temos um link com alguns
restaurantes né que já aderiram a esse
produto estão fazendo essa ponte também
de divulgação desse produto e também do
nosso trabalho não só do produto em si
mais mostrando como é produzido
acreditamos que trabalhar
agroecologicamente correto é
economicamente viável que o mais
importante acho que ninguém trabalha de
graça
eu sempre falo isso que a gente trabalha
por um propósito e a parte econômica
está em jogo tal estamos consciente e
seguro de que podemos continuar
incentivando os sistemas agroflorestais
porque um passe comunidade pois
agricultores e é economicamente viável
pelos não só pela parte financeira mas
também pelos benefícios que ela traz
para a saúde
nossa e do planeta espero que vocês têm
a oportunidade de conhecer sistemas
agroflorestais e comprovar isso que
estou falando aqui agora e tomar
consciência incentivar também não sei se
elas são sebastião já têm sistemas
agroflorestais gostaria de saber para
fazer a ponte
mas se não tem alguém de vocês começa a
pensar nos sistemas agroflorestais
também muito obrigado